all right ted well sheriff joe lombardo
delivering the department's annual state
of the department address today it was
also his last as he is now of course
running for governor as mary jane bill
yester reports a big topic of discussion
crime in the valley and how to fix it
sheriff joe lombardo's state of the
department address covered several
topics from deadly crashes to murders
and how to fix them in 2022. he says
there has been an increase in total
crime in the last year
what has been my priority since i've
been your sheriff first and foremost has
been violent crime and why is that
because it affects everything we do in
our community everything our quality of
life
how we look at our community our sense
of well-being or safety a major concern
is the surge in homicide rate increase
of 49 percent
that's a big number that's an individual
life associated with every one of those
increases
deadly crashes in the valley are also on
the rise sheriff lombardo recommends
expanding traffic enforcement we had an
eight percent increase in fatal
accidents
14 year high
for the state of nevada
14-year high across the state increase
in fatal accidents to the tune of 20
percent for the state
we have to be aware of that so we can do
something about it sheriff lombardo adds
this annual address helps shape the
department for future success as an
organization
we have to be aware of what we're
getting ourselves into we have to be
aware where we came from so we can build
on our success and not repeat the
mistakes and that is the purpose of this
today
so everybody is aware we can all speak
with one voice reporting in the newsroom
mary jane villasa live local now
metro is also hiring more staff
reviewing the budget and continuing to
fund programs needed for training and
community partnerships